hello everyone and welcome to what is
definitely uh already uh one of the
greatest games ever played it was played
in round six of the Romanian
championship between Grandmaster gergeli
Andres Gula Zabo and fide Master uh
nicodin cosmin estepenen soon uh this
game is so complicated that I will not
even bother you with their names I will
I will refer to them as Zabo and Steve
it doesn't really matter because the the
moves here are so incredible uh you guys
will really enjoy this one okay if it's
probably not the greatest game ever
played for me it's uh of course the Nish
medino versus chernik of 1962 Soviet
Team Championship uh but you know to
each his own for you very well this
could be the greatest game you've ever
seen now let's check it out uh there is
quite a lot to enjoy here so uh Zabo uh
has the white pieces and he opens with
Ponte E4 we have Pawn to C6 uh Steve
goes for the Karo Khan defense we have
D4 D5 and now the advanced variation of
the Karo Khan we have Ponte E5 and
Bishop F5 now you might be wondering are
we seeing the the bayonets in this video
not really at H4 the tile variation we
have Pawn to H5 and now Bishop to D3 uh
very very nice that what will probably
be considered the game of the year it
features a tal variation with Bishop to
D3 Bishop captures Queen captures and
now there are two main lines here for
black one is Z6 the other is Queen to A5
check outers really aren't uh ever
played uh because uh you know the
engines uh just say so so Queen to A5
check going for the second most popular
line Knight to the D2 and now Ponte E6
with Knight to F3 and now Knight to H6
you could also go to E7 and then to F5
uh everyone just goes Knight stage
sexier probably you don't want to block
your Bishop for some reason I have no
idea what the reason is uh because the
Knight always ends up on F5 so here we
have Castle's Knight to F5 and now Pawn
to C4 this has all been played before
nothing new here the Knight is on a
spectacular Square on F5 because H5 has
been played and you don't have to worry
about the G4 at any point so Bishop D7
putting pressure on the H4 pawn and pawn
to G3 we have castles and now Pawn to B3
again all been played before nothing new
here we have rooked the d8 and now uh
there are a couple of games that reach
this position the most notable one being
from 2019 that ended in a draw between
uh Zhang Zhao and uh Quang Liam lever
Bishop tabitu was played but here we
have Rook to D1 and it is now as of move
13 that we have a completely new game
and the black replies with a wonderful
strike in the center Pawn to C5 makes
sense the queen is on D3 you do want to
open up the center the characters and C5
and now Queen captures on C5 here black
if one if black wanted to continue in
great style then maybe Knight to the C6
but okay Queen characters and C5 Bishop
captures was also an option uh Knight to
F1 now uh and uh Here Comes D captures
on C4 and this is a deadly dare to give
um uh someone who who already appears to
be a very aggressive player you know
what he will play here and he is um uh
to do more than 200 rating points high
rated than you of course Queen capture
some d8 has happened here so Queen
captures and d8 uh it's a queen
sacrifice but basically a queen for rook
and Bishop with a very very active play
and if you guys are interested uh what
does our good friend the engine think
about this move well the evaluation is
0.00 so it's a nice position uh you can
play it King the H7 and now comes Knight
to E3 if you go Knight the G5 check
right away King G6 there's no good
follow-up here for white so white needs
to bring more attackers closer to the
black king So Knight to E3 now comes
Queen to A5 and this is a very nasty
move putting pressure on that uh Rook uh
also uh you could maybe capture then
white will not be able to capture also
if the Knight moves you can bring the
the queen T1 with check also the five
point will hang if you move the Knight
so the queen on A5 really controls
everything but here comes Knight to G5
check King to G6 and now the incredible
Knight to G2 offering a full Rook uh but
if you capture The Rook it's game over
if the Rook is captured then look at
this Knight to F4 check King to H6 and
now Knight captures on F7 with check
forking the king and the Queen and after
he move just Knight captures Europe a
full piece um as you can see you have a
bishop your opponent doesn't you're
gonna capture on E6 have a fast pawn and
this is of course completely winning for
white so black uh our good friend Steve
here finds an incredible refutation of
this idea he plays Knight captures on G3
and indeed if the Knight is captured it
would be very very bad for example if
you have captors on G3 now Queen
captures on d8 is perfectly fine because
now Knight to F4 check King to F5 and
after something like Bishop to E3 you
can play Knight to C6 the king is super
safe on F5 there is no Checkmate and
black defended well black will win this
game so instead after Knight captures on
G3 we ignite the F4 with check King to
F5 and now Knight captures on F7 uh very
nicely done now The Rook can come to f8
and also the Knight can come to D6 with
check which is a huge problem look at
this queen to C3 now attacking the the
rook and it would be it would be pretty
bad if you if you play Rook to B1 then
the queen can come to C to attack the
rook and the bishop then it to check and
come and you would uh slowly but surely
eliminate the attackers around the black
king but here the the spectacular King
to G2 offering another Rook here but of
course if you capture this Rook it will
not end well for you if you capture this
then Knight the D6 check and now look at
this King captures on E5 uh now uh if
you could play this it would be great so
let's play Knight captures and C for
check now the Knight controls the B2
square and you cannot remain on the dark
Square on the dark squares so King to F5
but now you play Rook to f8 check King
the E4 F3 check and now the only square
that remains is a dark square and once
you play this bishop the B2 check will
win back the queen so cappers captures
and you're just up too much material
here you are completely winning so
instead after King to G2 Knight the E4
was played uh but now comes Rook to f8
and uh remarkable as it is as this is
one of the craziest positions that we've
ever analyzed on the channel uh the
engine says yeah this is 0.00 nothing to
worry about here and the way to actually
play this is the plane Knights the D7
you add you have to offer The Rook on A8
but white can not capture this if you
capture them Queen captures and A1 is
possible and then you're just down
material without any sort of attack
uh but even getting a draw here would be
incredibly difficult night the D6 with a
double check you have to go for this
King to G4 now Bishop to E3 now you are
threatening Ponte F3 with check so here
uh if if you capture The Rook then of
course F3 checking captures an H4 and
Knight the G6 will be Checkmate so
that's out of the question you're gonna
have to play Knight captures on E5 uh
and now uh look at this Knight captures
on e4 Queen to C2 now attacking the
Knight and now you have to settle for a
trade here Rook captures Queen captures
an E4 with check King to G1 and now
Knight to F3 with check and this
probably ends up in a draw for example
King F1 B5 you attack The Rook row goes
after the black king and now we will
probably we would probably see a draw by
repetition here with something like
Knight H tonight to have a three check
repetition but instead of this after
Rook the f8 uh he did not find Knight to
D7 uh he played King to G4 which makes
sense you want to get away from all the
checks but now the position is
completely winning it's actually a
forced mating seven and the only reason
why I'm not calling this any mortal game
is because white missed this forced line
uh a lot of moves are winning here for
white but there's just a beautiful force
made in seven so feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
always need to sacrifice even more
material and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show that it is night
the H6 with check and that's it uh if
you capture here the Knight the G6 is
checkmated there are no squares our good
friend the bishop covers G5 and if you
don't capture if you go uh for example G
captures on H6 then comes Knight to D3
and this is the real star move that you
have to spot Knight to D3 uh because now
both the Knight and the bishop cover the
F4 square and there's no defense against
rookdale for checkmate it's I mean it's
just stupid uh here whatever you play is
just Checkmate there's nothing you can
do even if you play King captures on H4
then there's Bishop captures on H6 again
uh not nothing can be done here and if
Queen captures on D3 Rook there for will
be Checkmate whatever you play Rook def
or will be Checkmate this is just uh
what a position so instead after this
King the G4 uh Knight the H6 was not
spotted that's the only reason I'm not
calling this any mortal Bishop to E3 was
played and now okay black does have some
chances of Defending but still white is
objectively still completely winning
Knight captures on F2 was played now
comes Knight to D5 another spectacular
idea uh comes with Tempo the queen is
attacked and it doesn't really matter
what you play if you play e captures on
D5 then this idea becomes possible
probably now
um uh Zabo spotted it as Knight to H6
now will be the only winning move and
after King characters on H4 Rook to F4
check Knight sorry Knights the G4 and
now just Rook the H1 check now this Rook
um comes back into the game as well in
Rook captures on G4 will be Checkmate as
it's also a double check from the bishop
and Rook so instead after Knight the D5
black is without options he plays the
the best move that is Queen captures on
A1 but it's not enough again Knight the
H6 with the check so as apple found
Knight to H6 only a move after the The
Immortal line King captures an H4 now
you have to play Bishop captures and F2
you don't want to play rookdale for
check now because the Knight can block
so Bishop captures doesn't have to with
check it's now actually a fourth mate a
force made in 14 King to G5 Bishop to E3
check King to G6 Knight to E7 with check
King to H7 now Knights the F7 going for
checkmate here so Knight to C6 you have
to guard the h8 square and give up The
Rook uh or okay Knight to D7 could be
played Knight the C6 is what was played
uh now Knight the G5 check King H6
Knight to F7 check into H7 repeating the
position once but now uh Zabo realizes
that he has to capture The Rook so
Knight the G5 checking to H6 Knight
captures on E6 another beautiful
Discovery King to H7 Knight to G5 check
King H6 Knight the F5 with check King G6
and not Knight the H4 with check King
has to go back to the H file only square
is the H6 square and now Knights the F7
with check King H7 Knight to G5 with
check King to H6 and now finally Rook
capture sunny and A8 and you're probably
thinking all right I probably saw
everything now in this game but no no
you haven't uh look at this now
Checkmate is being threatened so black
defense spawned to G6 very nicely and
the only move that uh stops Checkmate
for the moment but here comes Rook the
G8 now threatening Rook captures on G6
Checkmate Knight captures on E5
defending the G6 pawn and now comes the
spectacular Rook captures on G6 we can
do it in slow motion now and it was in
this position on move 43 uh that an
accordion cosmen steppenenzo resigned
the game as there is nothing more uh to
be done here the only move he has is to
accept the rook and after 9 captress on
G6 at night the F5 check will be
Checkmate and what what a spectacular
game a double knight checkmate the
bishop covers the Knight on G5 uh white
white sacrificed everything and was it
was just a just an amazing amazing game
and what's uh what's remarkable is that
like in my favorite game and ninja
medino versus uh chernikov 1962 Soviet
Team Championship uh the the queen
sacrifice uh after you allowed the
engine to evaluate the position for uh
for long enough actually gives a 0.00 so
it's a it's it really is a beautiful
positional Queen sacrifice and here it
worked like a charm uh stepping in so uh
was defending well but at some point uh
he he didn't find that crucial
continuation that is uh Knight to the D7
here but I mean who finds this it's uh
anyway it's such a such a silly silly
idea and uh like no one finds this
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you you have
remembered everything about this game
because you really need to show this to
as many people as possible especially on
a chessboard like not just don't just
send them the link like uh you know go
go for a beer or for for some coffee you
know bring a chessboard and then show
them this game uh everyone needs to see
this game like today uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Tony and I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube uh Anthony
Moore uh chess ally.com and the medicine
Modi for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day